Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
picking up and continuing on where we
left off last week with regards to
the of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and learning
the
purpose of our existence.
And notice the wording that is used
here,
learning the purpose of our existence
because this is something that has to be
learned.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks to the
prophet Muhammad Sam
and he says,
He says to him
that prior to the revelation of this
book,
you oh Muhammad did not know what the
book was, what revelation was, nor what
faith and eman and belief is. It's
something that has to be learned.
It is something that a person has to go
out of his way and he has to seek out
knowledge
from its proper sources in order to
learn the purpose of his existence to
get the answers to those questions that
will inevitably catch up with us sooner
or later.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophet sallall.aii
He says, "Before the revelation of this
book to you, you were unaware. You were
amongst the unaware from mankind
with regards to the generalities and
specificities of the worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala alone without any
partners.
And so we mentioned
last week what the real
point of contention was between the
prophet sallall.aii wasam and his
antagonists.
When we look at it from this angle, why
did the Arabs
ofQures,
some of them even his own family
members, why at the beginning of his
message and through the majority of his
message did the majority of his people
fight against and reject what he came
with.
We understand
that already the people of Quraysh
viewed themselves
as the envoys,
if you will, of Allah to the house of
Allah, the Kaa. And they viewed
themselves as the caretakers of the Kaa.
And they referred to this as Al Hamasa.
And they referred to it as being people
who were chosen by Allah to be
caretakers of his house because the
Arabs in the entire Arab Peninsula would
migrate and would come for pilgrimage
every year for Hajj to the house of
Allah. It was incredibly lucrative for
them
and they believed that they were
essentially chosen by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and cut from a different cloth.
And so then we have our prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii
to top it off from amongst
and revelation comes to him. You would
think that they would be accepting to
this message. You would think that they
have every incentive
to accept this message and to bolster
his claims to prophethood.
However, we find that the majority of
them fought against him especially at
the beginning. Why is that? What was the
real point of contention? the real
issue.
And this is important for us to
understand
because we are trying to learn
what was it about the statement
that the prophet came with
that was so
offensive to them. Why did they find
this so offensive? Why did they fight
against it so vehemently?
And
the answer to that question is because
it invalidates
the worship of other than Allah.
This statement invalidates
the worship of the idols of their
forefathers.
This statement invalidates
the idea
that we worship Allah through the
worship of others or that we worship
Allah
and we worship others along with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This was the point
of contention. So when he said
[Silence]
They understood
because of the language that they spoke,
because of the Arabic tongue that the
message of Islam came to them In they
understood that upon conceding
they now have to forfeit the quote
unquote legacy of idol worship that they
were upon they and their forefathers.
This is why they fought against him. And
you see really what the difference
between Islam and other than Islam is.
Because
a lot of times we imagine
that
the oneness of Allah
is epitomized
in
believing that there is only one
creator.
Belief that there is only one creator
is not particularly unique to Islam.
Most of humanity believes that. Most of
humanity who believes
in a creator believes that that creator
is one.
Even religions built and based on the
worship of idols Hinduism for
instance,
they still concede that there is one
what they call God head. Some call him
Brahman, some call him Krishna, some
call him different names for him.
And this supreme god head is the one
creator of all that exists.
Even the Persians at the time, the fire
worshippers, the ma magians al- Majus
that the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
encountered as well. They believed in
two creators, the creator of light and
the creator of darkness. And that the
creator of light, you know, they said
there's two creators, creator of light,
creator of darkness. This has been
iterated throughout eastern religions
the yin and yang, destruction and
construction
or the chaos and the harmony, these
two sides, dark and light.
But even they concede that these are not
two equal gods.
They say there's the creator of light,
the creator of darkness. But the creator
of light is better than the creator of
darkness because from light comes good
and from darkness comes evil. Therefore,
they are not equal gods. The human being
is not going to logically arrive
at a conclusion that there is more than
one creator
who has created the heavens and the
earth with such harmony. Two independent
creators with their own independent
agency and free will. It's impossible.
It's a logical fallacy.
And so the majority of mankind
conceds that there is one creator. Even
in the time of the prophet Sam
when they would come for and what would
they say? This is what they would say.
They would say
this first portion we still say today.
It was affirmed by Islam.
Then they would continue to say
at your service, oh Allah, you have no
partners.
You have no partners except for some
partners that you have but you own them
and they own nothing.
So when Islam came it stopped this part.
It cut off the bad that addition at the
end and affirmed what was correct from
the religion of Ibraimis
that they were taught from is
This is where we stop. That addition is
from the innovation of the human mind
introduced into the pure religion and of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so the
issue was never believe that there's
only one creator.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
throughout the Quran
If you were to ask them who has created
the heavens and the earth, if you were
to ask them, who's them? The themm here
Abuahab Abu Jah Abu Sufyan at the time.
Uhbayf,
right? If you were to ask them who has
created the heavens and the earth, they
will surely reply to you, Allah. Allah
is the creator of the heavens and the
earth. And so the argument
that the Quran taught the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam that Allah taught
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
was. Ask them who has created them, has
created everything, has raised the
heavens, has set up the mountains, has
made the earth hospitable enough to
live in for your benefit, who has
protected you, who has allowed you to
reproduce, who has created you, who has
done all of this, they will say Allah.
Then reply to them, if Allah is the only
one who gave you this and did this, then
why do you worship other than Allah?
Worship only Allah. This is the point of
contention here. This part of worship
only Allah. This is where the point of
contention between our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and his antagonist.
As a matter of fact, this is the point
of contention between the majority of
the people and their prophets and
messengers that come to them. The point
of contention is worship Allah alone.
They say
we worship Allah but we worship others
along with him because the idea is all
rooted in intercession.
What is intercession? A
she Allah talks about intercession often
through the Quran and he tells us
intercession belongs to Allah alone.
There will be no intercession on the day
of judgment except for whom Allah allows
to intercede. Why are these things
repeated? Because this goes back to the
root of their belief system. This is the
logical
conclusion that they allegedly
arrived at. Here it is.
They say Allah is grand and awesome.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala and he is too
awesome and too grand and too majestic
for us with our lowly sins to go
directly to him.
and he is very unlikely to listen to us
when we call. However, he has other men
from amongst mankind
whom he has chosen to be as saints,
right?
He has chosen them to be as saints.
They're very close to him. They don't
have any sins. They are close
servants of Allah whom he has chosen
whether they be angels or prophets or
righteous men, right? And so if we go
and we appease these saints
and we get on their good side,
they will intercede on our behalf with
Allah. Just every king
has cordiers
and you can't go directly to the king,
you have to go to the courier. You get
to know him. the ambassadors, the
courters, the ministers. You go and you
speak to them and you get on their good
side and you give them gifts, right? And
then you ask them for favors and they
put in the good word for you with the
king.
And so Allah refutes this idea
throughout the Quran and he tells us
that this is the root of their belief
system. These idols that they worshiped
and who are mentioned in the Quran also
the idols of the people of NIM
that are mentioned in the Quran. These
are fashioned after righteous men
who
passed away but they believe these
men were very righteous men. And so they
constructed either monuments or
you know
either either monuments or
idols or statues in their image or in
their memory
that marked and signified these
righteous saints. And so they would
worship these idols
hoping that these,
you know, this idol represents this
particular saint that this saint will
accept from me and he will then
intercede on my behalf with Allah. He
will intercede on behalf of his
constituents with Allah in this life.
This was the idea. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says regarding their belief
system, he says
that they say
we only worship these idols so that they
may draw us nearer to Allah.
And 99.9%
of all idolatry, all idol worship, all
polytheism
in human history and on the earth today
is predicated on this idea of
intercession.
It is predicated on this idea of
intercession. And it has even seeped its
way into
what are referred to as the you know
the the three religions or the the
the divine religions or the Abrahamic
religions. Catholicism for instance
modern Catholicism
is
basically
idolatry. it is the worship of pretty
much everyone except for Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. The saints and St. Peter and
St. Paul and saint this and you say a
rosary for this one and you you wear a
pendant for this saint and they you know
and they will intercede on your behalf.
When you chant, your chants are not for
Allah. They are for Mary, right? Mother
Mary and Jesus and so forth in order
that they can draw us nearer to God and
draw us nearer to Allah. This is the
point of contention.
The people of Hud summed it up. They
said to
They said
to their prophet,
the people of they said to their
messenger Houd, they said, "Have you
come to tell us to worship Allah alone
and leave off the worship of the idols
of our forefathers?"
This was their argument.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala ends their
story by saying
and they were not believers. Why?
Because when you hear this worship Allah
alone they used to worship Allah. They
did they worshiped Allah but they
worshiped others along with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so h came and said you worship Allah
and these others yet Allah is the one
who does everything you have to be
thankful for. Why would you worship
others along with Allah?
Worship Allah alone without any
partners.
This was the point of contention.
This was the point of contention between
the prophets and messengers and their
people. They're antagonists. This is why
people fought against them. And so when
we speak about the purpose of our
existence, it is not just to believe in
the creator.
Belief in the creator is not
particularly unique.
However, it is that we worship only that
one creator and that we worship that one
creator only in the way that our
messenger has taught us. That's the
meaning ofahill
those two conditions
worship Allah alone without any
partners.
only in the way that the messenger
wasallam has taught you.
And this these are the two conditions
for deeds to be accepted.
When a deed is done for Allah, those are
the two conditions. It has to be for
Allah alone and it has to be in
accordance with the sunnah of Muhammad
sallall.aii
And you look for those two conditions,
you find them all through the Quran.
Most notably the final verse of
that we are to read every week.
Whoever wishes to meet Allah and have
that meeting go positively, then he is
to do righteous deeds
and not associate in the worship of his
lord anyone.
We will continue this inshall
next week.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah
Allahb.
Oh,
[Silence]
All
speech.
A mother
[Silence]
Oh,
you're
[Silence]
Oh,
no.
[Silence]
You're aligned.
Hallelujah.
[Silence]
Allah
long Oh,
[Silence]
heat.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Are
Bethch.
[Silence]
Muhammed
In this verse
in
Allah subhanahua
says to the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam teaching him to convey
to convey to men and women from all
walks of life with every imaginable sin
with every imaginable past
to say to them,
"Do you not then repent to Allah?"
And Allah indeed is offforgiving, most
merciful.
This verse
came
after a number of verses in which Allah
subhanahua
speaks about how the people who were
entrusted with his revelation
the followers of the prophets and
messengers
from amongst the people of the book whom
Allah entrusted
with his revelations.
to preserve them, to not add or take
away from them, to convey them to the
people as they were taught them.
And they did not fulfill this
entrustment
and they introduced new things into the
religion of Allah.
They introduced new ideas
such as the worship of his prophets and
messengers
of them.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
indeed they have disbelieved those who
claim that Allah is the
Messiah son of Mary.
Indeed, they have disbelieved those who
claim that Allah is the third of three,
etc. These new things that were
introduced into the religion of Allah.
However, after all of that,
after such treachery from their
scholars, after
the misguidance of mankind, and what
could be a greater slander and claim
than to claim that the creator of the
heavens and the earth has taken a son or
is one of his messengers or one of his
creations,
The mountains themselves
wish to crumble
from the majesty of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. How could we claim
that a human being, a man with all of
his faults and deficiencies and
weaknesses
could be
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala or be a part
of Allah or be the son
of the creator. This is a great slander
and a great lie against Allah.
However, Allah Subhanahu Waaala
says after all of that,
but do they not repent to Allah?
He is still opening the door of
repentance even for
those who have committed such atrocities
against the messengers of Allah.
He says subhanahu
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala indeed those
who have burned the believing men and
women burned burned
this is regarding a story of a king who
took it upon upon himself
to have his army dig ditches and
everyone who saidahillahill
be burned alive in these ditches.
Yet Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says after
relating this story indeed those who
have burned the believing men and women
and have not repented for doing so then
for them is the hellfire.
Even such an egregious act of rebellion
against Allah the door of repentance is
still open.
the hope of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And what is the Quran if not a book of
hope?
Imagine humanity
grappling with all of its insecurities
and weaknesses,
its oppressive nature.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala pierces
the heavens with a beam of light.
He sends down his most majestic of
angels Giblam
and he comes to the messenger of Allah.
Wasam with such verses as
say Allah is one and only and unique.
And so this book of hope,
which is the Quran,
has not closed the door of hope upon
anyone as long as breath is in his
breast.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has been described by the prophet
sallall.aii
as
[Silence]
And Muslimb
Omar narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said, "Indeed Allah
does extend his hand in the night so
that the sinner of the day may repent to
him. And he does extend his day his hand
in the day so that the sinner of the
night may repent to him. And he will
continue to do so until the sun rises
from the west."
Omar narrates that the prophet Sam
said in
he said
indeed Allah and all of his majesty
and might
does accept the repentance of any
servants of Allah of any of his
servants. servants. As long as his soul
is not being taken out of his body
actively by the angel of death,
a person has hope up until that moment,
up until the angel of death is there
extracting his soul.
Why is it that
that door of repentance
slams shut in the face of a person when
their soul is being taken out of their
body because that is not unique. Every
human being will repent at that moment.
Everyone,
every human being will repent at the
moment when he or she sees the angel of
death taking his soul out of his body.
At that moment, everyone repents. Even
Fon,
even Fun himself repented at that
critical moment.
However, up until that last final
fleeting second,
a person who repents to Allah, Allah
will accept his repentance
until the sun rises from the west
marking the commencement of the day of
judgment. Allah will accept the
repentance of his servants
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
not want to punish his servants unless
they have chosen that punishment.
He says, "Subhan,
what does Allah desire or want with your
punishment? As long as you believe and
are thankful and indeed Allah is ever
thankful all knowing
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is describing himself to us as being one
of gratitude subala
that when we do good in his name he
thanks us he thanks us for that good and
he rewards us subhanahua
and he forgives us and he puts a little
more light on our path
and he gives us a little bit more speed
on that path to redemption.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
given us every opportunity
to repent
and to make our final moments even if it
is just a moment of our life the best.
and that which will turn around the
entirety of our past.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
the most egregious of sins.
He tells us subhanahua
of the worship of idols, the murder of
our fellow man,
the
fornication and adultery that human
beings engage in.
And he mentions to us in the closing
verses of surah
the great punishment for such sins.
But then he bookends this by giving us
hope and telling us subhanahua.
[Silence]
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala
except for those who repent to Allah and
work righteous deeds
for indeed Allah will exchange their
sins for good deeds. This statement here
that when a person repents to Allah,
Allah will exchange their sins for good
deeds. What does that mean?
It's a very curious sentence and it's a
very curious idea
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
exchange their sins for good deeds
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
not just judge you on something that you
have done
but when you meet Allah subhanahuaaala
he judges your past
based on who stands before him.
And so when a person comes before Allah
having repented,
this person can't change his past, no
matter what he does, he cannot change
it. It's in the past. It's unreachable.
But if he could, he would.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes
this into account in his judgment. And
when a person comes before him
repentant,
when a person comes before Allah having
changed his ways,
all of those moments of sin that he
committed in his time of ignorance,
Allah will exchange those sins for good
deeds. Why? Because the person who is
standing before him in that moment on
that day of judgment if he could go back
this is what he would have done and so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala exchanges
those sins for good.
This is what our prophet sallall.aii
Wasam tells us Allah will do with those
who repent to him on the day of judgment
in Muslim in the book of im in the book
of belief
narrates
that the prophet Sam
said
on the day of judgment a man will be
brought before Allah
for judgment
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will say
to his angels,
"Hide away his bigger sins from his
scrolls
and only bring forth his minor sins."
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will then
proceed
to remind this man about those minor
sins that he committed. Do you remember
on this day, at this time, in this place
you did such and such? The man will say
yes. Do you remember at this time, on
this day, in this place, you as well did
such and such and you continued upon
this and such and such. And the man at
this point will believe that he has no
hope left,
that he must go to the hellfire because
he's meeting with Allah and Allah is
only bringing up the bad that this
person has done.
But this man will realize that there are
other more egregious sins that are not
being mentioned. But he's not going to
mention them. He's already in a world of
hurt. Why would he bring that up? And so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will then say
to his angels,
"Exchange all of the aformentioned sins
for good deeds."
And so the man will then say and
proclaim to Allah.
He will then say, "Allah, but I have
other sins still that you didn't
mention." He will say this because he
sees that now Allah has exchanged his
sin for good because he repented to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and he met
Allah repentant and he met Allah having
changed those ways and so Allah accepted
from him.
This is one of the three most major
warships
that are the hallmarks of our
of our bliss and admittance into
paradise on the day of judgment.
Three things the human being at every
moment in his life is in one of three
moments.
He is either in a time of ease and
blessing
in which he is required to be thankful
or he is in a time of hardship and
difficulty in which he is to be patient
or he is in a time of sinfulness
in which he is to be repentant.
These three traits
are the hallmark of the people of
paradise.
They are those whom when they are
blessed and given, they are thankful.
When they are tested and tried, they are
patient.
When they are sinful and make mistakes,
they are repentant. These three, the
more intensely
and more and the more pronounced they
are in your person, in your life, in
your in your nature,
the more
likely and the more elevated you will
be in the paradise and reward of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Repentance.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said in Muslim,
[Silence]
he said,
"I swear by Allah,
I swear by Allah that if you all were
free from sin, Allah would do away with
you and replace you with a people
that would sin and then ask for
forgiveness and he would then forgive
them. What does this narration mean?
Many of us have heard it.
Some think that well isn't this a a u
isn't this something that will cause a
person to sin more? No, this is not an
encouragement to sin and it is not
because of our sin that we remain here.
What is meant by the narration is one of
the purposes of your existence,
one of the reasons Allah has created
you, one of the dynamics of your worship
of Allah is repentance.
And you find your perfection in your
imperfections.
And part of our relationship with Allah
is built and based upon needing Allah's
forgiveness,
upon needing to be forgiven by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so we sin.
But the best of us are those who repent
constantly for said sin.
And indeed those who turn to Allah,
Allah will not turn away.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala has said in
his book
that indeed Allah does love those who
are in constant repentance. Notice the
wording here.
The wording here is not Allah loves
those who repent. It is more than that.
Allah loves those who are constantly
repenting.
Constantly in constant repentance. Why?
Because our sins are constant. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us that it
is repentance that it is that is
repeated and consistent
which helps to solidify our repentance.
A lot of times people become
discouraged.
They feel guilty for something that
they're doing or many things that
they're doing. All of us feel guilty.
Every one of us. There is not one
innocent man here amongst us or woman.
Every one of us is guilty.
And so what is the difference between
us? The difference between us is in our
repentance to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But we get discouraged
because we feel guilty and we repent.
And then we find after a day or two or
10 or a year or two, we start to slide
back into our old habits.
And then we try to repent again. But
this time it's not as fervent as the
first. And with each repentance, it
becomes more and more weak as we are
overtaken
by this sin or this habit. And this is
exactly what a shan is looking to do.
It is not an issue of a person repents
once and all of their life is perfect
after that. That doesn't exist. That's
not how it works.
Our repentance
is an issue of winning each individual
battle at a time against our enemy as
shan. You will repent as shan will
whisper. Then you will repent and a
shaitan will whisper. Can he get you to
become hopeless?
Can he wear you down until you can't
look at yourself anymore in the mirror?
Can he whisper to you, "What do you
think this salah that you're making is
going to do when you've done such and
such? You are so and so. You're just
fooling yourself. You're just wasting
your time. You know what you're doing.
You know what you're going to do as soon
as you leave from here. Why are you
trying to trick yourself and fool
yourself into this? These are the
whispers that we deal with. And what is
your estimate of Allah Subhanahu
Wa'ta'ala? Is your sin
greater than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala?
Is that what you will concede to?
Imagine the arrogance, the hubris that a
person has to have to believe that his
sin is so special and he is so unique
that Allah will not forgive him.
That is not that is not a
depression or that is not alone that
comes because a person really believes
that Allah won't forgive him. These are
the kinds of whispers from a shaitan to
make us think that my sin is special.
Everyone else could be forgiven but not
me. I'm special through my sin. Your sin
is not special. My mistakes are not
special. Countless men and women on this
earth have come before us and have
committed acts far
more serious than we. Yet our repentance
is what makes us special. Our repentance
to Allah is what makes us unique with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so you
continue with that fight. You make a
mistake, you repent. You make the same
mistake, you repent again. And this time
even more. And you continue upon that
path until a shan tries to look for some
other way to break you. Because he is
not going to continue to try to urge you
to repent. If that's what's happening,
he'll stop and he'll find some other
avenue.
And 10 good deeds will always beat out
one evil deed. And w and and goodness
will always prevail.
[Silence]
All
thatch. for
[Silence]
genetic.
for
[Silence]
Muhammad. for
Mother,
[Silence]
Allah
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps. Align your shoulders and
your feet with the shoulders and feet of
your two neighbors on either side of
you.
Please double check your phones. Make
sure that they are silent.
Do not join or begin a new line until
the one before you is completed.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
for
Allahb
[Silence]
Allahbar
Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
him.
Amen.
[Silence]
Allah
Allahbel
Allah,
Allahbel.
[Silence]
Take this over.